do you think that was a successful move
given the state of the world as it is
um
do you think people are happier do you
think they're more fulfilled do you
think they have the same level of
purpose as they did 60 years ago uh no
they don't because oh my God this is a
it's another complicated message
um because before they used to have a
lot of discipline into that so they will
they will have a list of things they
will have to follow in order to be a
good father or to be a good wife and
have kids and a solid family and values
that we don't have anymore because it's
too much Freedom now so so then wouldn't
that kind of contradict what you said
like parent rules somewhat good yes okay
church-wise because you're saying in
general right I'm saying okay in um
General in the population I'm feeling
this now there's too many rules
everything is too free there's too much
Freedom now so people are getting more
weak you can always feel like I'm mental
health people can do too much now I
don't have no guidance anymore but at
the same time church at least what they
want to see in Italy I don't agree with
that I don't respect that because
Church always like have people believing
in that but most likely they they get
people that are lost they don't have any
they're easy to indoctrinate that's what
it to me personally that's what it is
because there's more like more a
worshiping type of thing more than
you're free to believe in what you want
and as long as you're a good person and
you're good with the other people as God
actually was saying right that's what
it's supposed to be about right but I
don't know I just don't like the church
and they were the past so they have to
get all these people there and more time
is just people that alone lost no
self-esteem crazy sad or yeah that's
great go ahead to be honest it's a
church it really is complicated things
it's a hospital you go there people
the reason why you you will see a lot of
people who are broken and hurt is
because that's where they're going to
heal for me what got me more connected
to church because I used to go to church
with my mom and it's like I'm just going
for the sake of grain with her I wasn't
getting anything from it like the word
like I'm hearing the part pastor
preached it just was I was not retaining
it I had to find God for my own self
found my own church I went from to
several churches but I wasn't
comfortable until I found the one that
I'm at now okay and being there hearing
the word it helped it healed me in a way
because when you do go to church you're
not going to go there perfect or
anything you're going to find a lot of
broken people and already if your mental
health is not 100 there you can't think
for yourself and you have a pastor that
is
not neces not necessarily teach him from
the Bible is adding his own knowledge to
it and kind of controlling the
congregation that's where it's bad but I
still believe there are good churches
there I'm at one now because they are
big on you knowing god for yourself
having that own relationship with God
and don't worship us you need to read
that Bible for yourself you may hear us
preach it's your own you have to take
that responsibility to go back do your
own research on that word that they've
preached and then yeah you can take it
from there don't let them control you so
I have a question do you think
um a lot of guys will talk about how
they really doubt like women in church
like the authenticity of them because
they happen to come to church at like 28
29 when times running out and they've
been ran through do you think that's a
fair critique not necessarily because
because it's like it's just kind of
convenient like right when you need a
husband now you're at church yeah like
yeah that's crazy now you're sorry
that's wild that's wild I go to quite
fairly a young Church there's a lot of
Youth there yeah so there's different
parts to a church there's like the youth
and then there's the oh no yeah I
understand there's different parts I
understand it's not everybody but I've
seen the trend I've seen like like I
talked to I've been to like many
different churches because I've moved
around a lot there's a trend it's like
between 26 ish to 35 yeah I can't speak
on that because my one is is quite a lot
of young people so I don't I can't speak
on that but I would say there's a lot of
people my age that have been ran through
like even me the reason for me going to
church is like I was living a lifestyle
that I wasn't happy with and I know that
I still got time on my hands because my
pastor does preach that he's just like
you can't expect to come to church at 35
where you should have changed their life
now so that's why it's important to know
God from a young age because it's like
you have different seasons and if you
miss one season it can set you back like
10 years do you think that keeps women
single though because they preach for
women to wait till they're married and
and you're basically saying telling like
you let the less guy hit it for free and
then you're saying oh you have to marry
me in order to have sex so you don't you
don't think and then like on top of that
there's only 30 maybe 20 men in the
church so it's not even and it's like
you're asking men to wait when you let
the last five guys go for free not
necessarily so it again it goes down to
you know God for yourself having a
relationship with God and in that time
God will speak to you men will come to
you because you will be tempted I've
been in church and I'm not gonna lie and
say I was perfect
I was still having sex for quite some
time whilst I was at church that that's
just because my inner self was not ready
but you're talking about you so I'm
talking from like a man's point but so
so what I'm saying is honest I'm saying
because that's one thing and I I
appreciate that like that's that's but
I'm saying like from a guy's point of
view like why would he wait when the
last guys got it for free because men
because men value Purity that's why
going to have somebody that's on the
same level as you so for example now I
know that I'm on this this journey but
it's not 50 50. so I'm saying like there
aren't enough men in the church for the
women so like they're not you can't say
like oh we should all wait because
they're not there I'm not saying wait
because you can still go out and speak
to guys but you kind of have to use
discernment and know that okay I have to
go for a guy that's ready to wait for me
to get me so that's why you have to be
wise when you're dating but to me like
what I'm saying is like I think that
keeps women single because I don't think
there's a lot of guys that are willing
to do that because
I know but I think the the real thing is
like it's like you made your bed lie in
it and if you wanted if you wanna I mean
it's if we want to live in a fantasy
world where all these guys are dying to
wait for born-again virgins but they're
not but then you can't even get why
women will remain single because it's
that there's no hope like you you didn't
say that I was a hoe let me just
continue being on her then because
there's no chance of me getting a good
guy
saying I think if you do go to church
and
you have been run through before
you know don't just put our blockers
because you've just started going to
church but
because I see your point right you've
waited so late in the day to change your
whole whole life and when I was helping
people online there was a lady that I
came across that were a name nameless
and she shared her whole past with me
and it was exactly what you're talking
about she had a really promiscuous past
and then she found God yeah and uh she
didn't she said to me I haven't been
with a man since and if I meet someone
I'll be with him but I see your point
because from a male perspective it does
feel like you're getting the wrong end
of the deal you know yeah because it's a
bad deal yeah and that's and the church
tells men to take that
a man in the church and so like on top
of that there's you're right there's
there's not the men there so even if we
had it all the girls or all the men got
married in the church like there could
still be 20 uh there'll still be what
like 40 of the women they're still
single that's why they die outside yeah
that's why they on the dating website
and live in a completely different life
to them going to church this is and
that's what's happening but if I'm a
Christian and I'm dating a guy I'm going
to bring him to church
or when I'm communicating with a guy I
said I'll tell him this is what I'm a
Christian
and then if he is willing to come and I
can't I'll pray on it there'll be signs
where I'll see that okay this guy is
just trying to see if he can hit do you
get what I'm saying well but all men
want to hit it that's like all men want
sex I I think there's actually like to
add on to this if there's any lady
watching this and she thinks church is
the answer I actually would flip on its
head and think
where a guy is going to be and where are
they going to be the most respectful
I've been in martial arts gyms my whole
life and I've never met a more
respectful set of men in my whole life
and they are predominantly filled with
men so to me it's like go create
leverage for yourself like it's funny so
I should join a martial arts gym yeah no
you should I'm I'm being serious and
they are
they can protect you right you know that
already because they're in a martial
arts gym they are the most respect some
of the most respectful guys you will
ever meet in your life you think they're
going to be violent and all this they
are not they are the the some of the
least violent people I've ever met but
the the thing the thing is with the
church like they'll have a guy that has
all the qualities that a girl is looking
for but if he he says I don't want to go
to church I'm never going to go to
church they say to turn that down
and it's like okay well then die alone
like I see that that's the thing I find
hard about religion in general yeah is
the you could have almost the perfect
match but because they don't sign up to
your rules that you then you can't
um marry them and I think I think it's
one thing if you're a virgin like I
think you can ask more and you're like
more competitive in the church but it's
like if you if you're not like why would
a church guy date you yeah like it's not
in the Bible you can't judge another
person who are you to judge yeah but at
the end of the day like if you really
are in tune with God you can't judge
another person based off their lives
it was my weakness your weakness could
be something else I have to accept that
and understand that that was you that
was your past so that's another thing
that I noticed about now today's society
is that people are so fixated on
somebody's past that was my because
because you're looking at this from a
woman's point of view like when you
think you're thinking from a woman not a
man man care about a woman's past women
care about a man's future and that's
what I'm talking so I'm saying like like
they might not they might say don't
judge but I'm sorry your actions say
something about who you are so so if I
was with a guy that for 10 years was a
drug dealer I'm sorry it's not bad a bad
thing to say hmm that might not be a
good husband and so if a guy wants to
say hey she was a hoe for this many
years like that's not going to be a good
wife I should go pick the pretty virgin
down the street like I think that's fair
I don't think that's judgmental I just
think that's your bed
um can I say something constantly if I
had the past which I feel no one should
like be defined from you you have past
actions anyway no a guy that goes to
church should not follow the judgmental
mindset because everyone got past but
personally I would lie I was like yes
I'm a virgin I'll get surgery down there
and that's enough I would never say that
you would never find out period
yeah but the thing is like guys aren't
dumb over a certain age like I'm sorry
if the girls come on like I've had girls
on the show and they're like 25 26 27.
as many
as men I was just banned on on talk and
Ties on
worm
a super thanks below every donation
helps and it helps make what we do
possible